ben swan journaliste d'investigation
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir ben soit merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france vous
êtes un précisément atlanta quelle est
l'atmosphère sur place est ce que la
colère est retombé à l'heure où nous
parlons solaire est un peu retour des
nuages ou vu beaucoup de manifestations
ou lors du week end
le restaurant wendy's a été incendié son
restaurant où richard brooks a fait face
à la police et a été un turbo fort de
jeu la chef de la police d'atlanta a
démissionné ce week end et la maire de
la ville a dit qu'elle va demander cette
émission mais en tout cas elle a
démissioné bien qu'elle construira à
travailler pour la municipalité
la colère est légèrement retombé mais
cela ne fait qu'ajouter au sentiment
général de frustration du contre la
brutalité policière
cela fait pas mal de temps maintenant
que je suis le sujet est beaucoup de
personnes disent que c'est très
différent du caadp george clooney parce
que monsieur boxait affronté la police
il a volé un taser il s'est battu et il
a tiré avec ses 15 heures sur la police
donc certaines personnes disent que
c'est différent mais pas les
manifestants pour leurs achats groupe
n'aurait jamais dû se retrouver dans
cette situation il était ivre dans sa
voiture il a proposé de rentrer chez lui
à pied on est capable de le faire il a
effectivement de se battre est de se
dégager pour rentrer chez lui mais on
lui a tiré dans le dos et c'est donc un
autre exemple d'une l'usagé excessif de
la force
justement reporter connaît le contexte
tellement explosive on se demande
comment effectivement ce genre
d'événements peut arriver à nouveau peut
survenir est ce qu'il n'ya pas justement
un côté on se dit la police qu'il faut
vraiment être rigoureux en ce moment
dans cette période particulièrement et
ne pas commettre ce genre de bavure de
surprenant donc cette affaire c'est que
si on regarde les vidéos comme je lé
fais les caméras embarquées qui montrent
prêts et bourses parlant avec la police
si on regarde la discussion riche books
n'est pas véritable il ne se dispute pas
la conversation et serait poli les
policiers eux mêmes sont polis ils leur
expliquent effectivement il a bu que ces
recherches est juste à côté et qu'ils
rentrent à tout simplement un pied chez
lui keynes que sa longue les pose aucun
problème
et lorsqu'ils essayent de l'arrêter
c'est à ce moment là qu'il essaye de se
dégager
donc c'est un fake une escale est
extrêmement rapide entre la police et
monsieur books qui mène justement à
asson sa mort ça pousse à tirer avec un
taser et peut-être que s'il avait été
tué alors peut-être que s'il avait été
touché à leur salut hors et étrangers
mais rien dans la vidéo semble indiquer
que cela allait arriver
rien du tout rien dans cette vidéo
n'indique que ces policiers étaient en
danger que leur vie était en danger
en tout cas au moment où les chapeaux
s'enfuit donc c'est la cause de toute
cette frustration il ya des lignes
politiques très clair les personnes en
faveur des réductions du pitch aidé à
politis est un exemple du genre de
choses qu'il faut éviter et les
personnes qui sont contre cette idée de
démonter la police disent non les
policiers se sont bien comportés et s'il
avait pu se défendre et bien sûr été une
bonne chose
donc c'est un moment supplémentaire et
c'est là qu'on trace une ligne
et on ne parle plus de ce cas
particulier on ne se demande plus est ce
que cette personne méritait de mourir
on se dit plutôt très politiquement ce
qu'il faudrait faire avec la police en
général vis-à-vis notamment des vies
noir alors le procureur du district de
falcon a indiqué que son bureau allait
décider d'ici le milieu de la semaine
des poursuites engagées contre ces
policiers est ce que la nature de ces
poursuites va être déterminante est ce
que c'est le genre de décision qui peut
justement exacerber les tensions au
contraire les apaiser
il s'agit de poursuites civiles
alors c'est une chose mais si il y à des
poursuites pénales contre l'agent de
police c'est encore autre chose
l'officier a été viré c'est déjà fait
l'autre a été mis en service
administratif mais la question c'est
vraiment y aura-t-il effectivement un
véritable procès pénal et est ce que cet
agent de police se retrouvera devant les
tribunaux les deux parties discutent de
ce problème et il ya toujours cette
ligne dans le sable
certaines personnes disent non il ne
devrait pas y avoir de procès et
d'autres qui disent eh bien écoutez
voici un policier qui a tué à 1 à mort
un homme noir il faut pas qu'il s'en
sorte
pour le moment ne cherchons pas les
solutions pour notre problème nous
entrons dans un débat assez vain nous
avons choisi nos postures nos positions
et il n'y a plus vraiment de débat on ne
se demande plus comment pourrait
alimenter et à améliorer la situation
je voulais aborder avec vous pour cette
rubrique vu de l'extérieur en france et
des rumeurs sur l'état de santé de
donald trump il est apparu vous savez un
diminué lors d'une cérémonie
militaire à ce que c'est un sujet dont
on parle beaucoup aux états unis qu'est
ce qui se dit il ment certaines
personnes s'inquiètent de l'état de
santé du président pense qu'il commence
à fatiguer avec les problèmes
économiques qui se portaient très bien
jusqu'à la crise dure coronavirus avec
le problème des manifestations dans tout
le pays et avec le taux de popularité du
président qui est très très bas donc
effectivement il semble en payer le prix
et on se demande s'il pourra soutenir le
tenir le coup au moins physiquement
sinon émotionnellement parce
qu'effectivement il semble très fatigué
mais il serait difficile d'imaginer que
cela ne ferait pas merci beaucoup benz
ouanna journée les investigations
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir